this video contains spoilers for
everything within the danganronpa
universe except for v3 if you haven't
played v3 than you're safe but be aware
that everything else is fair game
enjoy the video I've been thinking about
all this at times like this
what would Sakura do you only get
stronger by taking adversity by the
horns confront that thorny path with
enthusiasm that sounds like something
she'd say right no I think that's
definitely what she'd say hello and
welcome to dung and Rampal 101 the
series it breaks down everyone and
everything in the danganronpa world and
today we are going to be delving into
the depths of the ultimate swimming pro
and donut enthusiast Allie Asahina our
Asahina is an incredibly friendly and
phenomenally athletic student who was
part of the seventieth class of hopes
Peak Academy and thus a participant in
the killing game featured in danganronpa
trigger happy havoc ow he is best
described as warm and pathetic and
exceptionally prone to her own emotions
I'll bring strong beliefs that made her
an invaluable asset during the killing
school life game for the most part I say
for the most part because one of her
other most notable traits is being just
ever so slightly too extremely airheaded
which makes are we very susceptible to
falling for traps and amongst the
easiest of the seventieth class to
accept almost any of I presented now is
also a pure powerhouse of energy and
holds a personal belief that she simply
must keep moving in order to survive
which has led to her joining no less
than six different sporting teams
however this is very much at odds with
her extremely gluttonous side Izawa is
also a huge fan of any sort of sweet
food with a particular obsession
dedicated towards delicious fried dough
rings better known as Donuts as a result
our often displays her fear of gaining
weight however that is all but
impossible given her active lifestyle
with a primary talent in the area of
swimming and thus leading her to be
accepted in hopes Peak Academy as the
ultimate swimming pearl unfortunately as
stated before this acceptance would lead
our to becoming sealed within hopes Peak
Academy when the tragedy struck the
world and owies memories would go on to
be erased by her fellow classmate Junko
Enoshima who then forced the remainder
of the seventieth class to participate
in a killing game now are we is one of
them all pure-hearted members of the
class and a particularly hard time with
the ensuing events of the game often
becoming depressed and mourning each
loss of the classmates that she had
developed such strong bonds with in such
a minimal amount
time and it should be said that the
strongest of these bonds was without a
doubt with Sakura organy the ultimate
martial artist initially the two became
friends due to the mutual interest in
physical activity particular niche diet
items and a general love of all things
fought this bond was so great that when
soccer was revealed to be monokuma small
against the class how he simply refused
to believe it and even when soccer iself
confirmed this fact now we still
continued to put her faith in Sakura and
of course when soccer committed suicide
Ali was hit the hardest even briefly
succumbing to despair with a little help
from some falsified evidence courtesy of
a certain moon monokuma of course but
for much of the fourth class trial Ali's
goal was to kill herself as well as the
rest of her classmates whom she believed
were to blame for Sakura's actions
however Aoi is eventually rescued from
this path of destruction by Makoto
and the remaining students and became
United in an effort to bring down the
mastermind of the killing game which
resulted in the defeat of the ultimate
despair Junko Enoshima as one of the six
survivors of the killing school life
game Allie went on to join the Future
Foundation determined to avenge Sakura's
death encountered the despair that had
spread throughout the world
unfortunately this led her to becoming a
participant in a second killing game
that was arranged under the guise of
putting her classmate Makoto naegi on
trial for treason within the Future
Foundation and while this game did
threaten to plunge all of the
participants into despair once more it
should be noted that by this time Ali
had undergone considerable mental growth
and despite the horrors inflicted around
her she remained strong with a profound
belief that she and her friends would
survive this game as well decide how he
to being a much more useful participant
in this particular game and even put her
combat skills on display during a brief
skirmish producer who was formerly known
as the ultimate boxer and this is
particularly important to note because
during this game each of the contestants
were given a forbidden action which
would result in their deaths if it was
performed and in ours case were
forbidden action was rather simply
getting hit by a punch or a kick and so
Ali's bravery would play an integral
part in ending this killing game after
which it was decided by the Future
Foundation that hopes Peak Academy would
be rebuilt and from here Ali worked
alongside her former classmates to bring
this to fruition
some more fun facts about Ali Asahina in
the bad ending of trigger happy havoc an
alternate reality is presented where the
remaining students live out their lives
within the confines of hosts peak
Academy with Ali being the only female
survivor and becoming the mother of
Makoto hagakure and presumably by Aki as
children prior to her life in host peak
Academy the closest person to ally was
her younger brother Utah who was an
exceptional swimmer although he himself
admitted that Ali was always better and
just to add to the mountain of tragedy
that has befallen Ali specifically you
two would be killed during the events of
ultra despair goes despite being a
survivor of killing school an execution
had still been planned for our we should
it have been needed and it was known as
the water illusion show whereby monokuma
would appear dressed as a magician with
Ali in a water tank he would then drop
the curtain and now he would proceed to
be eaten by sharks and by the time the
current was raised again there would be
no remains sounds very familiar doesn't
it like a certain other execution that
would be used in the future so just in
case anyone was interested other than
swimming the five other sports how we
engage in and excelled at were baseball
basketball volleyball tennis and track
and field
Ali is also one of only four characters
to have survived to killing games within
the danganronpa series but the others
being Makoto naegi Kyoko Kira Giri and
Hajime Hinata and finally a truly
useless fact about underwear during her
high school days are we apparently wore
plain white underwear which whilst
comfortable did come with a slight
drawback for her as they became
see-through if she swam with them but
that pretty much does it for our wee
Asahina if you enjoyed this video and
the content this channel produces in
general then please do consider donating
to the new world review patreon because
the support of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible and if patreon isn't
quite your style and please do leave
this video a like share or subscribe
because it also helps support this
channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my discourse
server where a wide array of shenanigan
retakes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with who what
aware you'd like to see teach it the
next danganronpa 101
[Music]
[Music]